lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
encontrar la longitud de arco de lo que
podríamos llamar un pétalo de la gráfica
de r igual a 4 seno de 2 teta
quiero encontrar entonces la longitud de
esta porción de la curva que está
dibujada en rojo esto lo voy a hacer en
dos partes en la primera parte voy a
establecer la integral definida para
calcular dicha longitud de arco y en la
segunda parte voy a evaluar la integral
con una calculadora con lo cual vamos a
obtener de manera inmediata el valor de
dicha integral
así es que manos a la obra te invito a
que le pongas pausa al vídeo y dado que
ya conocemos la fórmula para la longitud
de arco en coordenadas polares intenta
aplicarla para calcular esta longitud
supongo que ya lo intentaste así es que
vamos a recordar la fórmula la longitud
de arco va a estar dada por la integral
definida desde el ángulo inicial hasta
el ángulo final desde el ángulo alfa
hasta el ángulo beta
la raíz de la derivada de la función la
raíz de la derivada de la función
elevada al cuadrado más la función r de
teta elevada al cuadrado
beteta veamos entonces cuáles son
r prima de teta y r de teta
déjame ubicarlo entonces por colores r
prima de teta r prima
mejor vamos a empezar con el re de teta
entonces r de teta en rd teta es igual a
4 seno de dos de tal
413 se receta y es re prima de teta de
prima de teta es entonces la derivada de
dos tetas 2 x 4 8 y la elevada de seno
es coseno coseno de dos tetas así es que
ahora podemos escribir la integral
definida para calcular la longitud de
arco como
l es igual a la integral definida cuál
es el límite inferior bueno el pétalo
que nos interesa inicia cuando ted es
igual a 0 radiales cuando tet es igual a
cero radiales eres igual a cero es este
punto que tenemos aquí así es que el
ángulo inicia en cero radiales y se va a
ir incrementando hasta llegar a y sobre
dos cuando te des igual a pi sobre 223
igual a seno de pies igual a cero y
regresamos a este punto así es que el
integral va de cero y sobre 2x sobre dos
la dian es y vamos a integrar la raíz
cuadrada
es re prima de teta al cuadrado que es 8
coseno de dos tetas al cuadrado
esto es entonces 64 deje ponerlo con el
mismo color azul
esto es entonces 64 coseno cuadrado de 2
teta más r de teta elevado al cuadrado
que es 40 2 teta elevado al cuadrado
esto es 16 seno cuadrado de 2 teta y por
supuesto que cambia extender esto aquí
de teta y aquí podrías intentar evaluar
esto analíticamente no es tan inmediato
yo voy a utilizar una calculadora porque
en este caso lo más práctico y es una
herramienta que tenemos que aprender a
utilizar así es que aquí voy a la opción
del integral definida presiono segundo
cálculos en mitad y 85 y ahí elijo la
opción de integral definida déjame
expresar entonces el integrando
la raíz cuadrada
de 64 x coseno de dos tetas al cuadrado
así es que jose no voy a usar x pues en
mi calculadora x es una variable más
fácil de indicar que te está entonces
coseno de 2x deja de poner bien los
paréntesis para que tome la función
coseno de manera adecuada coseno de 2x
elevado al cuadrado aquí cerramos otro
paréntesis y elevamos al cuadrado ahí ya
tenemos la primera parte más
+ 16
que multiplica
que multiplica al seno
al seno abro paréntesis de 2x cierro
paréntesis
cierro paréntesis elevó al cuadrado de
hecho yo no sé si aquí atrás lo toma
directamente la calculadora mejor a
poner el signo x para indicar 64 por
coseno de 2x elevado al cuadrado más 16
por el seno de 2x elevado al cuadrado
ahora voy al final y aquí esto voy tengo
que cerrar la raíz y aquí ya no
necesitamos cerrar el argumento de la
raíz cuadrada con este paréntesis ya
tenemos bien el integrando ahora como la
variable con respecto a la cual estoy
integrando que es x cada que aparece
teta aquí le estoy sustituyendo con x y
queremos evaluar la integral entre x
igual a 0 y x igual a p
sobre dos y ahora sí espero que no haya
cometido ningún error a la hora de
teclear lo y así vamos a obtener
está tomando su tiempo pensando espero
que no que no se haya trabado no ahí
está obtenemos redondeando a milésimas
9.688 así es que esto es aproximadamente
igual a 9.688 pero tratemos de obtener
alguna aproximación del valor para ver
si está correcto el pétalo se extiende
hasta un radio de 4 por lo que si tan
solo fuéramos de ida y de vuelta
tendríamos una longitud de arco de 8
pero tenemos lo que se abre el pétalo
así es que el valor que obtuvimos de
9.688 si parece adecuado y así hemos
concluido